und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten guten abend
im kampf gegen das corona virus werden
die instrumente geschärft mit denen eine
entschuldigung eine hohe vierte welle im
herbst verhindert werden soll
eine allgemeine testpflicht für
reiserückkehrer steht seit tagen im raum
den start zum ersten august hatte
bayerns ministerpräsident sünder gestern
hier im heute-journal schon angekündigt
die bundesregierung ließ den termin
heute aber offen die abstimmung lauf
erst noch gleichwohl die testpflicht
wird wohl kommen denn noch ist die
impfquote nicht hoch genug
inzwischen sind gut 61 prozent der
deutschen bevölkerung einmal geimpft bei
denen doppelt geimpften wurde die 50
prozent hürde genommen 50,2 sind es
exakt ein gutes halbes jahr nach dem
start der impfkampagne zu wenig ist das
für eine herdenimmunität die mehr als 80
prozent erfordern würde
und so geht es nun nicht nur um ins
anreize für erwachsene
der blick richtet sich auch wieder
verstärkt auf die kinder sollten auch ab
12 jährige geimpft werden um
schulunterricht zu ermöglichen und
überhaupt zum nutzen der gesellschaft
eva schiller
wenn dr prügel von behandlungszimmer zu
behandlungszimmer hetzt ist in diesen
tagen eine diskussion dauerbegleiter
soll ich mein kind gegen korona impfen
ja nein vielleicht sofort die einen
fürchten die impfung die anderen corona
und alle fühlen sich unter druck gesetzt
die unsicherheit ist immens groß weil
einfach jeden tag irgendwo eine andere
meinung durch die presse getrieben wird
ja und der druck ist eben auch groß weil
wird immer mehr familien haben wie zb
vater mutter sohn geimpft das große
geschwister mit 1890 das geimpft und
jetzt hab ich noch ein kind mit 14 was
mache ich jetzt mit dem die delta
variante droht und mit ihr neuer
homeschooling stress aber die frage ob
es legitim ist kinder zu impfen um die
gesellschaft zu schützen diese frage
spaltet eltern dass man zugespitzt
formulieren also wenn wir jetzt davon
ausgehen dass für niki wird ein kind
selber die impfung nicht nötig ist damit
das kind sicher ist dann ist es einfach
wieder nur ein opfer das muss herhalten
das kind dass die härten immunität
hergestellt wird ist die einfache
möglichkeit für die politiker dazu da
sagen wir impfen jetzt einfach die
kinder also das ist ganz klar wüste geld
in die hand nehmen
die schulen und strukturieren kleiner
pieks mit großer wirkung so wird bayern
zünder für kinder impfen so oder so
ähnlich hallte es aus vielen politischen
ecken der chef der ständigen
impfkommission verbittet sich diese
politische einmischung hauptargument für
eine impfempfehlung müsse der schutz der
kinder sein
wir haben das sehr gründlich analysiert
und da sieht man dass das risiko für
schwere erkrankungen bei den kindern in
deutschland sehr gering ist die zweite
frage ist der impfstoff wirklich sicher
genug und dazu muss man sagen die
zulassungsstudie mit ja sehr wenig
geimpften kinder lässt eine aussage dazu
nicht zu was ist für kinder und
jugendliche riskanter eine corona
infektion oder die impfung erst der
internationale studien deuten darauf hin
dass im schnitt bei 2 von 100.000
geimpften eine herzmuskelentzündung
auftritt im vergleich dazu erkrankten
nach einer corona infektion von 100000
zwölf- bis 18-jährigen im schnitt 30 an
pimps einem entzündung syndrom das
verschiedene organe betrifft und longo
witt an der freiburger uni klinik wollte
man sich auf minderjährige mit lankowitz
spezialisieren
aber es kamen so gut wie keine
mittlerweile zweifelt man hier und
anderswo
ob longo wird bei minderjährigen
überhaupt ein problem ist denn eine
studie zeigt dass nicht infizierte
jugendliche ähnlich erschöpft waren
die jugendliche mit vermeintlichem
longkou witt wenn es die erkrankung gibt
glaube ich ist sie extrem selten das
sind geht das ist das was wir bis jetzt
wissen und was wir eben auch sehen ist
dass wir in den vergleichsstudien die
eben einen eine vergleichsgruppe von
nicht infizierten jugendlichen
untersuchen
dass wir dort auch hohe
belastungsfaktoren messen es gibt gute
gründe kinder und vor allem jugendliche
jetzt schon zu impfen findet dr prügel
vorerkrankungen oder sozialer teilhabe
aber eltern sollten sich nicht unter
druck setzen lassen sondern sich lieber
zeit nehmen denn jeder monat mehr könnte
mehr klarheit bringen
und bei mir ist jetzt professor fred
zepp bis märz weil direktor der kinder-
und jugendmedizin der uniklinik in mainz
und mitglied der stiko ist er auch der
ständigen impfkommission die im moment
ja praktisch wöchentlich tagt auch heute
gerade wieder professor zepp jeder monat
könnte klarheit bringen haben wir gerade
gehört darum bemüht sich ja die stiko
auch gerade was die zwölf- bis
17-jährigen angibt geht da gibt es eben
noch keine generelle impfempfehlung wie
und wann bis wann gewinnen sie diese
klarheit und auf welchem weg mit welchen
daten ja eine ganz wichtige frage die ja
auch wächst aber deinen beitrag
angesprochen wurde
ein professor märz hat schon gesagt wir
müssen prüfen welches ziel können wir
mit einer impfung erreichen also
schützen wir kinder oder jugendliche vor
schweren krankheiten oder geht es nur um
die übertragung oder geht es tatsächlich
nur um sekundäre ziele also zb
schulbesuch wobei dafür braucht man
keine impfungen aber zum beispiel jeder
herstellung von freiheitsgraden und ich
sag mal für die zulassung der impfung es
ist so gewesen eine zulassungsbehörde
wie die immer die prüft zunächst
europäische die europäische
zulassungsbehörde oder auch die
amerikanische fde die prüfen die
zulassungsunterlagen eines herstellers
heißt sie prüfen ob das was der
hersteller wünschen erfüllt ist in den
studien und dann gäbe es eine zulassung
und wenn dann ein risiko wie zum
beispiel die herzmuskelentzündungen
auftreten
dann schreiben sie einfach in die den
beipackzettel rennen da ist ein risiko
darüber müsste aufklären die aufgabe der
stiko zum beispiel aber ist es für die
betroffenen die geimpft werden sollen
die bestmögliche empfehlung zu
entwickeln das können wir aus den
studien nicht in der studie für den
impfstoff der in deutschland entwickelt
wurde haben 1131 kinder teilgenommen in
der studien usa für den zweiten
bergenheim stoffe etwa
zweieinhalbtausend da kann man kein
risiko erkennen dass jetzt wie hier ein
beitrag wurde gesagt ein zu 50.000 die
amerikaner haben wir haben viele mehr
geben die sagen einmal unter 20.000
impfungen kommen
zu so einem ereignis das heißt sie
werden diese daten aus und müssen dann
im grunde ab werden nicht nur eine ein
allgemeines risiko sondern schon ein
spezielles auch für jedes kind das
individuelle risiko dass die geimpfte
dass der jüngste mensch im prinzip einen
dass das muss man sehen
und wie gesagt da haben wir sagt mal die
amerikanischen gesundheitsbehörden haben
das ein bisschen anders in der
risikobewertung gehabt tatsächlich sind
in amerika etwa 135 jugendliche ein
qubit 19 verstorben völlig andere
situationen wie hier in deutschland wo
wir fast keine krankheit was sehen und
insofern haben sie gesagt das risiko der
muskelentzündung ist möglicherweise für
uns geringer wir werden diese daten
sehen und die kontakt für tag hinein und
dann müssen die einfließen die in die
individuelle risiko betrachtet das kann
noch dauern herr professor z oder kann
man da nächste woche mit rechnern
ich kann nicht genau sagen uns nächste
woche ist aber es ist tatsächlich so
dass man den usa in großem umfang
angefangen hat mitte mai zu impfen das
heißt wir müssten eigentlich jetzt in
diesem monat die zweiten impfungen dort
vollendet haben wir wissen auch dass man
dort dreistellige zahlen von hand
muskelerkrankungen gesehen hat die auch
alle zum teil so verlaufen sind das die
kinder oder jugendlichen in jugendliche
sind es jahr ins krankenhaus mussten
und insofern würde ich sagen in den
nächsten zwei bis drei wochen müssten
wir tatsächlich daten dazu sehen bis
dahin jedenfalls sind ja doch viele
eltern ziemlich verunsichert wie sie
wollen alle das richtige tun für für
ihre kinder sie können jetzt das
ergebnis nicht vorwegnehmen aber sie als
kinderarzt was ist aus ihrer sicht das
richtige ja also ich muss sagen wir
kinderärzte haben ja das ziel möglichst
die kinder die wir betreuen auch zu
schützen und das gilt natürlich auch für
impfungen die deutsche gesellschaft für
kinder und jugendmedizin kümmert sich
intensiv hat eine eigene arbeitsgruppe
zu sich aktion ein mittel sicherheit im
kindes und jugendalter und wir müssen
wissen kinder und jugendliche sind eine
besondere altersgruppe überlegen sie mal
ein neugeborenes verdreifacht sein
geburtsgewicht in zwölf monaten und in
der pubertät gibt es enorme
veränderungen hormoneller natur die alle
auch das immunsystem beeinflussen das
heißt wir wissen nicht genau was dort
geschieht jetzt gibt es ja impfstoff für
die ab 12 jährigen montech ab heute auch
moderner reden wir mal über die was
würden sie da empfehlen also genau wie
die ständige impfkommission das schon
vorgetragen hat zu diesem zeitpunkt ist
es so dass wir empfehlen vor allen
dingen kindern mit chronischen
vorerkrankung
ein erhöhtes risiko für eine schwere
erkrankung haben zu impfen das ist schon
eine harte empfehlung und das geschieht
auch und das ist wichtig das heißt also
kinder mit herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen
lungenerkrankungen und manche
stoffwechselerkrankungen immunologische
funktionsstörung thumann bei den anderen
kindern die grundsätzlich gesund sind
ist es so dass wir im prinzip im
augenblick ein blick darauf haben welche
bedeutung haben die herzmuskelentzündung
auch da haben wir dreistellige zahlen
mittlerweile schon gefasst und dann muss
man im prinzip sagen solange dieses
risiko nicht zuverlässig gegen das doch
sehr geringe risiko von erkrankungen
durch saas kauf 2 durch das virus nicht
aufgewogen wird ist es ist es eigentlich
mal aus meiner sicht als kinder erzieher
sicht eine sicherheit die wir den
kindern geben vor allen dingen wir
können den eltern auch sagen das risiko
in dieser zeit mit geringer inzidenz der
kranken mit geringer zahl der erkrankung
für die kinder ist enorm gering
also insofern lohnt es sich zum schutz
der kinder auch was das arzneimittel
oder das impfstoff angeht diese woche
noch abzuwarten bis dass wir mehr
klarheit über das leben begrüßen sie
haben den korridor genannt zwei bis drei
wochen dann ist man vielleicht schon
weiter vielen dank professor zepp
hierfür den besuchern sehr schnell die
vielen dank die korona krise macht die
politik nervös denn wie sie die kuchener
krise die wahlentscheidung beeinflusst
ist unkalkulierbar
zumal wenn wir ende september mitten in
einer vierten welle stecken sollten
es ist dieses jahr ein besonderer
außergewöhnlicher wahlkampf einer um
einen leeren amt sessel quasi um den
sich gleich drei bewerber bewerben der
spd-kandidat olaf scholz hofft dabei
nach wie vor auf den effekt lachender
dritter im lasche zu unbestimmt wem
berbalk zu unerfahren ist der könnte
sich vielleicht für den vizekanzler
erwärmen so das kalkül seine
persönlichen werte sind gut doch die
seiner partei mäßig heute hatte scholz
als letzter der drei einen auftritt bei
der frauenzeitschrift brigitte
klaus brodbeck und andreas huppert
bericht keine kandidaten keinen kandidat
kennt das land wohl länger als diesen
und erlebt dann doch so etwas wie eine
überraschung der mann ist mensch nicht
nur
am morgen ich bin langschläfer aber es
ist schon lange nicht mehr dazu gekommen
so manchen themen werden finanzminister
ihr selten gefragt kanzlerkandidaten
aber schon was will scholz tun für mehr
gerechtigkeit für für hinrichtung seiner
was will ich konkret ab 27 september
genau ich will erstens endlich
durchsetzen dass das gleiche löhne und
gehälter
und das heißt dass wir auch nicht nur
gesetze machen müssen in denen die
unternehmen verpflichtet werden für
lohngleichheit zu sorgen sondern dass
wir auch dafür sorgen dass in den
sogenannten frauentypischen borussen
besser bezahlt wird denn das würde schon
eine ganze menge ändern und dazu gehört
auch ein gesetzlicher mindestlohn von 12
euro der würde zehn millionen
bürgerinnen und bürgern dieses landes
ein besseres gehalt bringen und die
meisten davon sind frauen
auch um stolze frau geht es britta ernst
selbst ministerin in brandenburg sein
persönlichster moment ich glaube dass
ich ein ganz anderer mensch wäre wenn
ich nicht mit britta ernst verheiratet
wäre
wir gehen jetzt davon aus dass ich ein
besserer mensch sind eindeutig ja
wird ihre frau weiter arbeiten sollten
sie kanzler werden findet licher weise
das eine frage die mich empört und ich
das ganz offen sagen es nicht ob die
auch männern gestellt wird die ehegatten
sind das war die dose liste frage die
ich in den letzten monaten gestellt habe
nach ihrer frau und ich finds zufolge
sie reagiert haben zur tagespolitik wie
umgehen mit rückkehrenden aus dem urlaub
scholz beruhigt jetzt suchen wir noch
nach irgendeinem möglichst pragmatischen
einfachen wenig belastenden weg wie das
als normaler vollzug von allen gemacht
werden kann ohne dass jetzt jemand angst
haben muss dass er nicht mehr nach hause
kommt oder so was
immer wieder geht es auch um die wahl
und scholz chancen hier eine
zusammenfassung am rande
jetzt kommt es darauf an klar zu bleiben
überzeugend zu sein die tatsache dass es
ja um die zukunft der nächsten zehn
jahre des ganzen jahrzehnts geht auch
immer wieder zu betonen weil dass es die
entscheidung die die bürgerinnen und
bürger treffen wollen sie wollen kein
wischi-waschi sie wollen auch nicht
irgendwelche befindlichkeiten kennen
lernen sie wollen wissen wie geht es
weiter mit unserem land 59 tage hatte
dafür noch es bleibt spannend
der wahlkampf läuft so die nachrichten
schauen heute auch zunächst auf das
explosionsunglück in leverkusen gundula
gause
nach der gewaltigen explosion im
leverkusener chemiepark gibt es kaum
noch hoffnung auf überlebende
die betreiberfirma erklärte man müsse
davon ausgehen dass die noch fünf
vermissten nicht mehr lebend gefunden
werden
bei dem unglück gestern waren zwei
mitarbeiter gestorben 31 wurden verletzt
in einem tanklager der sonder
verbrennungsanlage waren organische
lösungsmittel in brand geraten
ob die rauchwolke und darauffolgende
niederschläge giftige substanzen
enthielten wird weiterhin untersucht
ermittlungen zur unglücksursache laufen
zwei wochen nach der verheerenden
flutkatastrophe ist die zahl der
todesopfer auf mehr als 180 angestiegen
73 menschen werden immer noch vermisst
in den teils völlig verwüsteten
flutgebieten sind nach wie vor tausende
helfer im einsatz
ein schwerpunkt ihrer arbeit die
versorgung der betroffenen mit
trinkwasser und lebensmitteln
außerdem muss der kontaminierte schlamm
so schnell wie möglich aus den häusern
geschafft und der müll von den straßen
geräumt werden mehrere hunderttausend
tonnen hochwasser sperrmüll sind in den
katastrophengebieten angefallen
die betroffenen in den flutgebieten
brauchen unterstützung allein über
unseren zdf spendenaufruf kamen bislang
fast 56,9 millionen euro zusammen und
jeder euro hilft das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe koordiniert die hilfe
die iban lautet de 65 100 400
600 104 106 100 stichwort zdf hochwasser
weitere informationen unter spenden zdf
de und im zdf text auf seite 8 190 der
machtkampf in tunesien spitzt sich
weiter zu nachdem präsident seit am
sonntag den regierungschef entlassen und
die arbeit des parlaments ausgesetzt
hatte
lässt er nun die staatsanwaltschaft
gegen führende islamistische parteien
ermitteln auch gegen die islamistische
konservative in achter mit ehering der
parteilose präsident seit seit monaten
um die macht behauptet durch seine
maßnahmen tunesien aus der krise führen
zu wollen
kritiker werfen ihm einen putschversuch
vor an der grenze zwischen armenien und
aserbaidschan ist es erneut zu kämpfen
gekommen drei armenische soldaten wurden
getötet
aserbaidschan bestätigte zwei verwundete
beide seiten machen sich gegenseitig für
die neue gewalt verantwortlich wollen
sich nun aber wieder an die von russland
vermittelte waffenruhe halten die usa
und russland haben in genf neue
gespräche über abrüstungsfragen
aufgenommen vereinbart von den beiden
präsidenten beiden und putin auf
grundlage des new start vertrages des
letzten noch verbliebenen abkommens zur
rüstungskontrolle in washington besuchte
beiden zum ersten mal die us
geheimdienste angesichts zunehmender
cyberangriffe warnte er dabei vor einem
so wörtlich echten krieg in folge der
cyber attacken
außerdem veranlasste beides regierung
weitere maßnahmen zum schutz der
kritischen infrastruktur in den usa
hinwil 70 jahre zurück am 28 juli 1951
wurde die genfer flüchtlingskonvention
verabschiedet entstanden um nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg die rechte von
geflüchteten menschen zu schützen ist
ihre leistung an diesem jahrestag
unumstritten
sie hat in den vergangenen jahrzehnten
vermutlich millionen menschen das leben
gerettet
die zahl der flüchtlinge nimmt weltweit
zu man muss sich das vorstellen
vertrieben oder schutz suchen sind
derzeit so viele menschen wie
deutschland
einwohner hat bevor wir auf ein beispiel
aus afrika schauen kamera farian mit den
fakten
[Musik]
noch nie waren so viele menschen
weltweit auf der flucht mehr als 80
millionen laut dem flüchtlingshilfswerk
un hcr für viele das wichtigste
internationale dokument zu ihrem schutz
die genfer flüchtlingskonvention vor 70
jahren in genf verabschiedet gilt sie
bis heute als grundpfeiler des
internationalen flüchtlings rechts 149
länder haben sich ihr inzwischen
angeschlossen der flüchtlings begriff
ist dabei eng gefasst er gilt für
menschen die ihr herkunftsland verlassen
mussten also aufgrund ihrer rasse
religion nationalität zugehörigkeit zu
einer bestimmten sozialen gruppe oder
wegen ihrer politischen überzeugung
verfolgt werden
und die flüchtlingskonvention garantiert
ihnen elementare rechte sie haben
anspruch auf ausweisdokumente und zugang
zu gerichten das recht auf eigentum
bildung berufstätigkeit und
religionsfreiheit
im gegenzug haben flüchtlinge aber auch
pflichten etwa die gesetze ihres
aufenthalts landes zu beachten
doch die genfer flüchtlingskonvention
steht auch in der kritik denn sie
schützt keine binnenflüchtlinge und auch
keine klima vertriebenen
dabei hat sich die zahl der
binnenflüchtlinge innerhalb von zehn
jahren verdoppelt auf 45 millionen
menschen
ja und dieses problem der
binnenflüchtlinge also derer die in
ihrem eigenen land auf der flucht sind
wird größer und drängender
das lässt sich beobachten am beispiel
äthiopien wo durch blutige
auseinandersetzungen in der nördlichen
krisenprovinz die drei millionen
menschen in not sind gestern erst schlug
der un flüchtlingskommissar alarm
essensvorräte und trinkwasser für die
menschen in den flüchtlingslagern gingen
zur neige
unsere afrika korrespondentin sandra
theis berichtet das also camp in der
amur-region in äthiopien
allein diesen knapp 2000 flüchtlinge
gestrandet notdürftig untergebracht in
zelten
viele haben schreckliches durchgemacht
nachdem sie uns angriffen haben sie
meine genitalien verstümmelt
sie haben meinen rücken verbrannt ich
habe schmerzen und außerdem gibt es
nicht genug zu essen hier viele sind
traumatisiert mussten zusehen wie
familienmitglieder und andere vor ihren
augen getötet wurden
die toten körper die ich sah es waren
hunderte ich bin oft tote getreten als
ich lief ich konnte nichts mitnehmen
alles was ich besaß musste ich zurück
lassen
äthiopien ist ein vielvölkerstaat mit
zahlreichen ethnischen konflikten im
november eskaliert der konflikt zwischen
der zentralregierung von
ministerpräsident ahmed in addis abeba
und der im bergigen norden des landes
regierenden volksbefreiungsfront von
tigray biach mit schickt truppen nach
tigra entmachtet die regionalregierung
die geht zu einem gerät krieg über
tausende werden getötet
ende juni dreht sich die lage
kämpfer aus tigra erobern die
regionalhauptstadt mit kehle zurück und
rücken seitdem weiter vor ihr ziel ganz
tief befreien
durch den konflikt wurden laut un 1,7
millionen menschen vertrieben
besonders schlimm ist die lage in tiger
selbst hunderttausende hungern
zehntausende flüchtlinge seien durch die
kämpfe von humanitärer hilfe
abgeschnitten
katrin die eingeschlossenen flüchtlinge
brauchen dringend lebensrettende hilfe
sauberes trinkwasser geht aus es fehlt
medizinische versorgung und der hunger
ist eine echte gefahr
hinzu kommen berichte über massive
menschenrechtsverletzungen und
gräueltaten begangen von allen
beteiligten parteien des konflikts
das schließt ein bewaffnete die frauen
und mädchen sexueller gewalt und
vergewaltigungen aussetzen tötung von
zivilisten ohne prozess hunger als
mittel des krieges mehr als fünf
millionen menschen sind schätzungen
zufolge auf humanitäre hilfe angewiesen
eine waffenruhe ist derzeit nicht in
sicht stattdessen werden immer mehr
soldaten rekrutiert er ist gestern
verabschiedete äthiopien 3000 weitere an
die front hilfsorganisationen wie heute
auch das deutsche rote kreuz fordern
eine größere aufmerksamkeit für das
problem und die situation der
binnenflüchtlinge
hier sei die internationale
staatengemeinschaft gefordert jetzt noch
einmal nachrichten bundes lag aus der
bundesgerichtshof hat in einem
grundsatzurteil die sogenannten comex
geschäfte als strafbar bewertet mit
solchen transaktionen hatten banken und
investoren jahre lang den start um
steuereinnahmen in milliardenhöhe
betrogen für den normalen bürger und die
finanzämter stefanie bareth kaum zu
durchschauende geschäfte die also
illegal waren ganz genau jetzt auch
höchstrichterlich klargestellt comics
geschäfte von investoren und banken sind
keineswegs quasi legales ausnutzen von
steuerlücken sondern betrug und damit
strafbar wer sich daran beteiligt begeht
vorsätzlich steuerhinterziehung und
darauf drohen hohe strafen in
deutschland
der bgh bestätigte heute das urteil
gegen zwei britische aktienhändler wegen
steuerhinterziehung dutzende
staatsanwälte ermittelten bereits seit
jahren gegen mehr als 1000 beschuldigte
im größten steuerskandale der deutschen
geschichte
auch beteiligte banken können sich nicht
mehr wegducken sie müssen den
steuerschaden begleichen
allein die hamburger privatbank warburg
muss rund 180 millionen euro
zurückzahlen
das urteil eröffnet nun gute chancen
dass sich der staat das geld von
weiteren beteiligten zurückholen kann
nachweislich geht es um einen
zweistelligen milliardenbetrag und denen
der deutsche fiskus betrogen wurde bei
comics handelte es sich um ein
ausgeklügeltes verwirrspiel mit riesigen
aktienpaketen rund um den termin der
dividendenzahlung die papiere schopmann
so hin und her dass das finanzamt nicht
mehr folgen konnte dabei wurde die
nötige steuer nur einmal bezahlt am ende
aber vom finanzamt mehrfach
zurückerstattet finanzexperten gehen von
der spitze eines eisbergs aus denn noch
immer ist diese art von steuerbetrug
nicht komplett trockengelegt
politik und den finanzbehörden bleibt
weiterhin die aufgabe die
zahlungsabwicklung rund um die
kapitalertragssteuer auch wirklich
betrug sicher zu machen
vielen dank stefanie nach frankfurt ein
kurzes aber heftiges unwetter mit
starkregen und orkanartigen böen hat im
südlichen oberbayern in mehreren
gemeinden schäden verursacht es wurden
straßen überflutet dächer abgedeckt und
keller liefen voll
die feuerwehren waren stundenlang im
einsatz die behörden warnen vor
autofahrten und spaziergängen in der
region rosenheim wegen herabfallender
gebäudeteile oder umstürzende bäume
auch im norden italiens kam es nach
starken regenfällen erneut zu
überschwemmungen und erdrutschen
rettungskräfte mussten allein in der
provinz varese am lago maggiore zu 40
einsätzen ausrücken
in der provinz como waren straßen
teilweise nicht passierbar menschen
durch erdrutsche in ihren häusern wieder
eingeschlossen in der lombardei wurde
für mehrere provinzen der notstand
erklärt morgen werden weitere schwere
unwetter in der region erwartet
und wir haben noch die gewinnzahlen vom
lotto am mittwoch
sie lauten wie immer ohne gewähr 18 11
19 31 47 superzahl 3 mehr auf lotto zdf
de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
sie ist einer der wenigen filmstars aus
deutschland die auch in hollywood
karriere machte franka potente vom
münsterland wo sie geboren wurde in die
traumfabrik von los angeles
ihren durchbruch als junge
schauspielerin hatte sie mit lola rennt
das ist lange her doch die rothaarige
lola blieb immer mit ihr verbunden
nun stellt franka potente als
regisseurin ihren ersten langen
spielfilm vor mit einem rothaarigen
helden übrigens eine hommage an lola sei
das aber nicht
barbara lueg endlose leere
nur dieser typen trainingsanzug auf
seinem skateboard lost time verlorene
zeit steht auf seinen händen woher kommt
er
wohin geht er es ist ein schlüsselbild
dieser geschichte ich wollte eine
geschichte machen über jemanden der so
mitten im leben noch mal neu anfängt
jemand der eigentlich so stecken
geblieben ist wieso eingefroren in
seiner jugend sie wäre dann eigentlich
so neu anfangen
marvin kehrt nach 17 jahren gefängnis
zurück nach hause
dorthin wo er als teenager einen mord
begangen hatte
haben sie sich daran gewöhnt er trifft
seine kranke mutter wieder seine heimat
nachbarn von früher in dem glauben seine
schuld verbüßt zu haben
doch im ort halt sie nach vielleicht
stimmt es auf dem papier aber wenn die
anderen leute das ihn nicht lassen und
sagen nee das wäre aber mit denen noch
ein hühnchen zu rupfen das ist uns
völlig egal ob du im gefängnis war es
aber nicht
dann
wird das immer die wahrheit sein
warum bist du zurück bekam wollen das
neue zuhause ist deshalb nicht bekannt
was du nicht da ist das weiß ich
es ist eine fast biblische geschichte
über schuld sühne und vergebung in der
maroden tristesse der amerikanischen
provinz mit einer wunderbaren kathy
bates ich bin die letzten verdammten 17
jahre und hilfe in diesem verfluchten
aus ungebrochen ich komm klar da ist
etwas in dieser geschichte dass dich
weiter graben und tiefer suchen lässt du
leistest noch mal hin und dann passierte
etwas in so vielen szenen
rom ist ein mutiger film extrem langsam
erzählt manchmal gar bleierne schwere
themen in einer welt zerplatzte träume
und doch blitzt auch immer so etwas wie
hoffnung auf intimität etwas das den tag
doch gut werden und raum für vergebung
lässt also was ich noch weiß das so gut
fußball spielen konnte
ich glaube nicht vergeben ist stillstand
und vergebung ist halt immer eine chance
nach vorne nicht vergeben ist natürlich
festhalten an etwas das kennen wir aus
beziehungen die in die brüche gehen
freundschaften das ist sehr kompliziert
und genau deshalb soll dieser film ein
plädoyer für empathie und zweite chancen
sein und dafür dass es nicht auf jede
frage eine klare antwort gibt warum hast
du sie gekillt
die antwort muss wird an dem kino
erfahren
das war es von uns nah sein möchte
meldet sich um 0.45 mit unserem heute
schon mal updates morgen an dieser
stelle
claus kleber
[Musik]
schon genannte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter was sie hier sehen ist ein
satellitenbild von sibirien und diese
bereiche hier das ist alles rauch weiter
areale sind mit rauch bedecke brennt es
ja schon seit einer weile und in diesem
jahr vor allem sehr viel und mit der
klimakrise wird das alles noch viel
heftiger wissenschaftler sagen die
brände die waldbrände neben weiter zu
zur orientierung sie haben hier unten
den baikalsee und nördlich davon also
weite bereiche mit rauch und das weiße
hier
das sind wolken ja schauen wir auf das
wetter in deutschland und da haben wir
es mit einem zwischenhoch zu tun das
sorgt für ruhiges wetter
ansonsten nähert sich dieses tief 4 und
wird dann mit dem umfangreichen tief im
norden zusammen dann für recht
unbeständiges wetter am wochenende
sorgen
schauen wir auf die nacht da gibt es
schauer und gewitter vor allem im
nordwesten deutschlands ansonsten ist es
aufgelockert teils klar im osten und die
temperaturen sinken auf 11 grad im
hessischen bergland und 16 grad zb im
osten deutschlands ja morgen
tagesverlauf weitere schauer und
gewitter vor allem richtung emsland
nordsee und schleswig holstein dazu
kräftiger teils stürmischer wind aus
südwest häufig haben wir es aber mit
sonnenschein zu tun ein recht ruhiger
tag und das bei höchsten temperaturen
von 27 grad im süden deutschlands und 26
grad im osten
am kühlsten ist es in schleswig holstein
mit 19 grad die kommenden tage am
freitag im süden teils kräftige gewitter
bis 27 grad
ja und das wochenende wird kühler und
unbeständiger mit zahlreichen schauern
mit 16 bis 24 grad
ein schöner ab